well it's the 25th anniversary of your
debut album
i mean it's it's rare when any artist
has an
album like pieces you know that kind of
effect on pop culture
and that kind of life-changing event for
one human like that changed your life
that album so how is it looking back on
that
you know this album feels like a magic
carpet i mean i don't know how many
words are on it let's say a thousand
a thousand words changed my life a
thousand words got me on the cover of
time magazine for representing hope
and kind of moving grunge out into a
different era it was
insane what this record did to me and
how it changed my life
yeah i think though it's because you
were so like just as a fan
it was just so pure and raw and honest
and not formulaic and
it was all the things that were like i i
feel like really needed in that time too
or
every time um but i i felt like you were
really different and that's what really
stood out and it was beautiful and
poetic
and i don't know we say we sing foolish
games together on your greatest albums
hit and i
are your greatest hits album sorry and
i've i i played it cool
but my um friend that was with me at the
time i was like i was like i
freaked out after like i was trying to
be really cool in front of you and not
do what i did with meryl streep
but like i was so excited that i got to
sing on that
i mean singing harmony with you is the
coolest thing you have the sexiest
female voice i've ever heard in my
entire life like it's so cool and poetic
and sexy and sweet it's so awesome
well i remember doing that duet with you
and i was just i mean i know your range
and i've been a fan of your voice
and of you as a person but hearing you
sing in person when i'm holding up that
long note
it's the very top of what i have it's it
that's the roof that's what i got
and then you were just like a good third
above it in your chest voice like
this is effortless how long should we do
it i'm just going to hang out a while
that's amazing no i'm going to be honest
you took all the air i feel like you
have like celine dion lungs and
your capacity to hold out a note is kind
of insane
um i was really nervous and trying to
bring my a game so i impressed you
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever help